Actually, I just had a mild reaction to k-seed, high reaction to cow dairy. I don't know what they're
separating that out then. No symptoms tested just to free up my immune system. Okay, good.
Well, really, you shouldn't be on any dairy anyhow for cancer because of the
not because of the inflammatory thing. So, if you have antibodies to a food, you're going to have
inflammation every time you eat that food. So, that's the reason why you would stay off of a food
that you have antibodies against. So, if you're eating something that you have antibodies against,
you're causing this hyperinflammatory response in your gut and in your brain every time you eat
that thing, that's why you want to stay off of it. And how can you gut heal if you're causing a fire
in the gut every time you eat? So, that's the whole purpose of doing a food sensitivity test.
Now, there's other reasons why you wouldn't want to eat certain things. So, like dairy, you'd stay
away from that because you have cancer because it has so many growth factors in it. Or gluten,
you'd stay away from that if you had thyroid issues because it's a molecular mimic to your thyroid
or gluten, you'd stay away from it. If you have antibodies to neural tissue, brain tissue because
it's a molecular mimic to somebody like myelin, she cells and alpha tubular cells and cerebellar cells.
So, you'd stay away from that if you have any early dementia issues like that, you'd stay away from
that and it's so inflammatory to your brain. So, you know, you don't even need to do a food sensitivity
test for those reasons. So, now, is there benefit to doing eating fermented dairy? Well, there's
probiotic benefit to eating fermented dairy. But, you can get fermented foods without eating fermented
dairy, which gives you the same probiotic benefit. So, with cancer, if your cancer is active,
I would not eat dairy. If your cancer is not active anymore and you're in a state of relative
remission, like me, I eat dairy again, but I don't we don't drink, but we have a drug milk for ages.
But I do eat some cheese and lots of times when we eat cheese, it's goat milk cheese. But it's
not only cheese, but not daily. So, you know, to stay away from dairy is just inflammatory,
so I don't eat it all the time like I used to. But I feel okay as far as it causing my cancer
to grow because I feel like, you know, I'm in a relative state of healing right now. So, but if my
cancer, when my cancer was active, I did eat 80 dairy. So, because of the growth factor issues,
not because of sensitivity. I don't have any symptoms when I eat dairy. So, hope that helps.